[Música]
saluda directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar y mañana es el día mundial de la
salud en la organización mundial de la
salud por este año concentraré una
relación entre el clima y nuestro
bienestar que bien no así es porque a
ver la la máxima principal es que no
podemos estar sanos en un planeta que es
tan tóxico exactamente las cosas que
vamos a hablar ahora de hecho no estamos
hablando de enfermedades respiratorias
por la polución desplazados climáticos
acceso al agua a la comida y la
contaminación que ella nos afecta de
hecho los micro plásticos en la sangre
por ejemplo que hablábamos recientemente
y que se acaban de descubrir entonces
bueno para profundizar en todo esto y
para entender mejor las implicaciones
que tiene que estamos con el doctor
oscar franco profesor de salud pública
en la universidad de berna doctor buenos
días y gracias por acompañarnos un
miércoles más doctor cuéntenos cuáles
son las consecuencias del alza de
temperaturas que sabemos que ya está
ocurriendo y que va a seguir ocurriendo
en los próximos años
mar antes que nada ahora que hablamos
del día de la salud y que hablamos de
salud es importante es fundamental
recordar que la amenaza más importante
que enfrenta la humanidad en cuestiones
de salud es la crisis climática es que
la crisis climática no solamente nos
afecta como individuos la salud
directamente sino que afecta también el
aspecto ambiental el aspecto social
cosas fundamentales como tener agua
limpia aire limpio como tener una
vivienda segura y poder tener acceso a
alimentos es algo que se pueden amenazar
debido al cambio climático y se estima
que más o menos entre 2030 y 2050 la
crisis climática podría generar unos 250
mil muertes en el mundo adicionales
debido a problemas como la diarrea
problemas respiratorios o olas de calor
entonces esto podría costar para el
mundo no solamente hablando de salud sin
hablar de otros temas entre más o menos
unos dos mil a cuatro mil millones de
dólares al año para el año 2030 lo que
podría destruir todo el progreso que
hemos tenido en los últimos años en
reducción de la pobreza y mejoramiento
de las condiciones de salud de la
población entonces es importante
recordar el cambio climático es ahora
mismo la amenaza más importante que
enfrenta la humanidad en términos de
salud y que dejamos a un lado todo por
esta guerra en ucrania y qué bueno
ponerlo otra vez sobre la mesa buenos
también saludarlo doctor le pregunto
entonces las enfermedades que podrían
extenderse más allá de sus regiones
actuales
si primero hay unas enfermedades que se
van aumentar y que se están viendo que
ya están aumentando no solamente en las
regiones específicas sino a nivel
mundial como las enfermedades no
transmisibles en ejemplo las
enfermedades del corazón o problemas de
salud mental y luego ya hay otras
enfermedades que son más susceptibles
del clima que con el cambio climático y
con el aumento de las temperaturas
podría empezar a afectar zonas que
anteriormente no se veían o que se había
dejado de ver y esas enfermedades podría
ser enfermedades como la malaria el
dengue la enfermedad de lyme
el cólera por ejemplo entonces lo que
estamos viendo es que con esos cambios
de temperatura donde afectan las
personas que afectan estas enfermedades
las regiones que se ven afectadas por
estas enfermedades se expandirían y
podrían afectar cada vez más y más
poblaciones sin doctor sabemos que el
uso de combustibles fósiles y la
contaminación que provocan hacen que la
gente tenga más enfermedades de pulmón o
por ejemplo de las vías respiratorias
también en cáncer de hecho recordemos
que la polución causa un muerto cada 13
minutos era una cifra de la organización
mundial de la salud pero también sabemos
que provocan muertes por infartos
por enfermedades diversas del corazón
qué relación hay entre las enfermedades
cardiovasculares y esta polución
si por un lado en lo que es el cambio
climático del aumento de las
temperaturas hemos visto que puede
aumentar la presión arterial y la
reacción del sistema vascular a las
diferentes estímulos que pueda tener más
allá hablando de la polución
directamente vemos que estas sustancias
tóxicas pueden ingresar en la manera en
que vamos respirando el aire que está
contaminado ingresa a través de los
pulmones pasa el corazón pasa a las vías
circulatorias y estas sustancias pueden
generar hacer que las arterias que los
vasos se hagan más duros que respondan
menos a la capacidad del organismo y
hacen también un proceso inflamatorio
que generalmente van generando un
problema crónico hasta que se manifiesta
ya con un infarto del corazón o con un
problema cardiovascular doctor sé muy
bien lo decía a la falta de agua y
alimentos y también otras cosas
derivadas a este cambio climático que
tanto nos va a afectar esto en nuestra
salud
utilizamos que entre un tercio a la
mitad de lo que es la producción
agrícola depende las condiciones
climáticas entonces si vemos que están
cambiando no solamente las condiciones
climáticas sin adicionalmente estamos
destruyendo el planeta en general donde
se puede cultivar los ecosistemas y
adicionalmente vemos que la población
cada vez aumenta más y se está
redistribuyendo cada vez tenemos más
gente viviendo más tiempo y por lo tanto
hay poblaciones más más que llegan a
edades mucho más avanzadas que requieren
más cuidados de salud todo esto si lo
ponemos en con un contenido tenemos que
pensar que en contexto tenemos que vivir
en un contexto de sostenibilidad y
pensar que mientras que la población va
aumentando también la producción de
alimentos se tiene que aumentar y no
podemos continuar en la forma como
estamos destruyendo el medio ambiente y
lo que nos permite alimentarnos
alimentar a la población
doctor una última pregunta muy rápida
deberíamos prepararnos para los cambios
que vienen ahora frente en nuestra salud
más allá de frenar el cambio climático
deberíamos estarnos preparando
claro es esencial ahora mismo el
comportamiento de las decisiones que
tomamos el estilo de vida tratar de
evitar tomar el coche del carro tratar
de tomar más la bicicleta hacer más
ejercicio y pensar más en sostenibilidad
pensar a largo plazo y cuidar al planeta
cada uno de nosotros puede contribuir a
cuidar al planeta
doctor gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros como siempre todos los
miércoles en directo américa de france
24 interrumpido un poco por la guerra
pero ya volvemos al ritmo